es el momento del año en el que las
temperaturas bajan mientras que las
cifras de kobe 19 van en aumento
actualmente europa es de las regiones
más golpeadas la mitad de los contagios
semanales se producen ahí a pesar de que
el número de pacientes de gravedad es
menor en comparación al invierno pasado
los hospitales temen una pronta
saturación como en múnich
estamos frustrados porque al final
nosotros tenemos que absorber todo lo
que no funciona en nuestra sociedad como
conjunto y tenemos que preocuparnos por
los enfermos que acuden a nosotros que
padecen una condición amenazante porque
necesitan ayuda en este caso no importa
si son activistas anti corona opositores
a la vacuna entre otras cosas ahorita
mismo solo hay pacientes que no se han
vacunado
aproximadamente el 80% de vacunación la
tasa en europa es alta en general pero
no en todas las áreas además las
personas que fueron inoculadas al
principio han visto disminuir su
inmunidad países están reinstalando
medidas sanitarias en países bajos entró
en vigor un confín parcial
yo creo que todas estas cosas pequeñas
pueden ayudar y creo que tiene sentido
el confinamiento mientras la gente no se
vacune te puedes hacer pruebas pero si
las personas no quieren vacunarse
entonces eventualmente tendrá que haber
reglas más estrictas
con
austria va más allá con un confinamiento
para las personas que no se han vacunado
en noruega un cierre total no es una
opción pero el gobierno autorizará que
cada ciudad decida qué medidas aplicar
como el uso del pase sanitario